our first guest is the main subject in
the harrowing documentary allen versus
pharaoh
in which she leaves no stone left
unturned
bearing it all about the abuse she says
she endured as a child
it is important to note that woody allen
has never been criminally charged
in connection with these allegations to
say this story has a very complicated
history
is an understatement please take a look
the new hbo docu-series allen versus
pharaoh
examines the abuse allegations involving
fame director
woody allen this series revolves around
dylan
farrow the adopted daughter of actress
mia ferro
and woody allen raised by someone
considered to be a
treasure of the cinema dylan's childhood
was once seen as idyllic to the outside
world but in 1992
when abuse allegations were raised that
all changed
ellen denies child abuse woody gave a
press conference
and our jaws dropped no matter what you
think you know
it's just the tip of the iceberg
dividing her family
hollywood and the public dylan's claims
of abuse and the latest interviews
bring us into her past trauma with the
aid of her brother
ronan and her mother's perspectives new
footage and recordings are shared
in this documentary seemingly supporting
the claims made by the then
seven-year-old dylan he made me feel
so special that's where things get
really really complicated because
throughout all of those good times there
was a lot more going on
woody allen and his wife sunyi also an
adopted daughter
of mia have consistently denied these
allegations stating that they are
quote categorically false it's taken me
a long time
to sort of reconcile that you can love
somebody and be afraid of them
an adult now dylan remains adamant in
her disclosures that she has repeatedly
stated for
the past 20 years she now uses her
platform to try and teach
other survivors to be brave and
resilient
themselves
i'm very honored to welcome the very
brave
dylan farrow
[Applause]
i feel like you look so different in
person do i oh my god
i have all my makeup on like normally
i'm like
if you saw me crawl into work every
morning i
look like someone they wouldn't let in
the building
and not the same way there was very nice
girl who
came to the hotel and she did it ahead
of time
and it was really cute my daughter got
to see all of her makeup stuff
she was very enamored of that so you
know
our life is in chapters and i think we
should hold this conversation
especially in honor of you being an
incredible novelist oh my gosh
with your brand new book out called hush
um i think i would love to conduct this
conversation if i may
in a writerly way to honor your
beautiful career and because i do
believe that life is a book
with many chapters i want to say first
out of the gate
too that i uh i would like to explain
myself because this is not about me but
i wanted to sort of have this type of
candor
i worked with woody allen i did a film
with him in 1996 called everyone says i
love you
and um there was no higher
career calling card than to work with
woody allen
and then i had children
and it changed me
because i realized that i was
one of the people who was basically
gaslit
into not looking
at a narrative beyond what i was being
told
and i see what's happening in the
industry now
yeah and that is because of you making
that brave
choice so thank you
for that thank you oh my goodness
hearing what you just said
like i mean i i'm trying not to cry
right now
um but like it it it just just
so meaningful because it's easy for me
to say like
of course you shouldn't work with him
you know he's a jerk he's a monster but
i just find it incredibly
brave and incredibly generous
that that you would say to me that
um that that my story and what
what i what i went through
was important enough to you to to
reconsider that
absolutely and
how hard was it for you
to engage in this documentary which i
really want to make a caveat
about that your family did not produce
no no they came to us i think that's
very important for people to understand
your family did not produce this
documentary we participated
and apparently everyone was asked to
participate
yeah no they they they went to everyone
um and and and that was important you
know
even just to me to know that like that
there was
a level of journalistic integrity at
work here so
did your family get together and say
these people are different they're
taking a tone they're using a diligence
there there's a thoroughness here
that feels safer in order to come out
and make this brave decision
um i was actually the one who
initially told my mom
and told ronan you know like hey you
know i sat down with
with these people and i really think
that they are on the up and up
so then when my mom
agreed to be interviewed i was really
really shocked
and when ronan agreed i was even more
shocked and then
fletcher agreed and i was i mean i was
picking
my job off the floor and you know
gradually more and more of my siblings
signed on and a few of them
didn't and i've spoken to them about
that
too and i i respect that decision as
well
um but i mean in terms of like a family
meeting
not really but um but there was
there was communication and
interestingly the the documentary has
led to
greater communication between us as a
result i think which is interesting
may i ask why you were surprised that
they signed on
i think mostly because
we wouldn't talk about it to each other
so talking about it
publicly it was just
it just seemed absolutely
incomprehensible how did your
mom feel watching the documentary
i mean it was tough because i would have
loved to have been able to
watch the series with her um
and at the time that just wasn't
possible we were
we were in separate quarantine pods
unfortunately
um so i really sort of
heard everything from her after the fact
you know it was just a very strange
pathway that we
navigated separately and together
but i think it it definitely changed
a lot about how we how me and my mom
relate to each other and interact with
each other and
i think there's a very renewed
level of just respect
just woman to woman
i mean sometimes when i think back
uh on memories of my life there has like
a gauze a patina a sort of
surrealist reverie um
i know mentally that time has gone by
but i also can feel like i can
be back there in a moment's notice like
that
um even if it does feel almost
watching a home movie and then
when you were watching the home movie
of you what did you think and feel
and remember it was a really
bizarre psychological experience for me
honestly because
i had the video in my house
um i gave it to my husband
and i just said put it into sort of like
the darkest corner that you can find
just know where it is and that
moment of just in case happened when
i was talking to amy and she asked if
she could see slash use the video in the
series and
my first reaction was like absolutely
not like no i draw the line here this
is too much it is too personal i don't
want to see the video i don't want
anybody else to see this video
and amy
i don't know how she talked me into it
she managed to get
the video taken i i had my husband
bring it out of that dark corner of
wherever he stashed it in the closet
and we watched it
on someone's computer and
my husband had to leave the room he was
like i can't
this is like this is too much and
i was just like completely numb i
watched the entire thing as though i was
watching
someone else just a little girl who
looked kind of like me who you know
sounded kind of like me
you know and i just completely
disassociated
from it and you know they went on their
way i was like
please just you know let me think over
using this and a week went by almost
like exactly
and i was sitting in my house and i just
suddenly burst into tears
and it just it hit me everything from
the tape just
i mean it punched me right in the face
and i was just sobbing uncontrollably
for like a couple of days on and off
about what i saw and just sort of
trying to mentally
reconcile the fact
that that little girl on the tape was me
and she was talking about something that
happened
to me and
it was overwhelming
it's very difficult sometimes
to know that that part of me
is such
a dark painful place
i mean because when i look at my life
now i have a wonderful husband i have a
wonderful daughter i have a wonderful
life and
i'm really excited about you know my
career writing
and you know taking my daughter to
kindergarten next year
and all the all the wonderful things
that
surround me and yet there is this
impenetrable darkness deep
deep inside that
i mean i'm gonna be honest i just i
still don't know what to do with
wow i would love
to talk about your husband how do you
go from having the life that you had
and and not being trepidatious but being
emboldened i really liked him i was
i was very smitten and i felt confident
that i wasn't like asking for something
ridiculous because i've you know seen
guys and i've been like
so what do you think of moving this into
relationship territory and they
just like book it and at the time of
course i internalized that as like
oh well this is because i'm messed up um
and so you know how did you not do that
with your husband
that is a really good question i guess
it was because
i really liked him he did try to break
up with me
and a lot of that was because i had
hang-ups about sex so i think it was
when he tried to break up with me was
when
it sort of crystallized for me that
this was something that i wanted um this
was something that i wanted enough
to address the things that he was
talking about the issues
which was sex which was from trauma
which was
from things that i did not like to think
about so
in a lot of ways
it really i think it started me sort of
on that path to
looking inward and examining myself a
little bit more critically
so then did you overcome that hurdle i'm
guessing
it's an ongoing process i mean because
in a lot of in a lot of ways i feel like
sex hang-ups
are something that grow with us and it's
just sort of confronting
the issues as they arise and not getting
discouraged by them i guess
i mean what is wrong with me has been
like
my mantra across my life and i'm trying
to change it because
it's an outlook thing it's an attitude
thing and
the fact that it's my knee-jerk reaction
you know
is because of trauma it's because i
internalize things and i think that
everything is my fault and i think that
i'm a failure and i'm you know again
like what
the the person that i am when i'm tanked
so today
say that crops up it rears its ugly head
how
do you whack them all that today what
would your inner dialogue be today to
thwart that demon
it's you know honestly i i want to know
the answer to that question too because
it is a work in progress and sometimes
it does feel like i'm flinging pennies
at a battleship and
you know that there's nothing i mean
like that i can
say or do for myself to myself
that will change anything because i'm
stuck and yet you're out there being
brave so what attempts did you
make to reclaim your life
you know like there are times when i'll
be
you know having a bad day and my
daughter will come home
from school and i'm just like okay no
now i am in mom mode i am
i am her mother now and this
this can't interfere with that i can't
let that interfere with
with her um because i don't want her i
don't want my problems to be her
problems
do you think that you're the most sane
when it comes to being a parent
i think being a parent has given me a
clarity
of being able to sort of
step outside of all the craziness in my
brain
and examine myself as who do i want this
person to be that my little girl
is going to see looking up to for her
entire life
i i want her to think
you know my mom was a fighter and i want
her to think you know my mom
never gave up and my mom didn't let
crappy people bring her down she you
know she stood up to people
she stood up for the things that she
believed in the things she was she
thought was right
um and i want to be that person too do
you know that you take on
a very different energy when you talk
about being a parent
i love being a parent i love being i
love being evangeline's parent i
you know she is just
the light that she brings to my life is
indescribable
is it the best thing that's ever
happened to your life
yeah it really i mean
i'm very lucky i have a lot of good
things in my life and evangeline
i feel has just elevated that
how do you deal with any fears that crop
up as a parent because i have
mine from my own history or my own
stories or things that are big triggers
to me
i mean i i think about that a lot
because i do
have things that trigger me in my daily
life things that you know
are probably just like completely stupid
for other people
that just send me
completely down the spiral and i'm
actually kind of proud of myself that
i've gotten to the point where i can
see a trigger or experience some sort of
trigger
i freeze and all that you know fun stuff
happens
the the emotions the the recall
the sensations and
i can process it
and sometimes it means waiting through
some of the negativity
how do you tell people to handle their
triggers
if you see an image
i mean i mean this happened to me like
last week maybe the week before i was
just you know scrolling through
my uh news feed and
an article pops up that
you know who and his his wife went to a
restaurant
and i was just tailspin
completely i was just like i can't
handle this i don't want to see this
like
why are they going to restaurants anyway
like
i was really very heavily triggered
and i was not okay and
it took a couple days
of me just sort of like
trying to like massage myself back into
a normal space can i ask do you
you know if people looking in who maybe
have not
experienced anything like this is it the
layers the repetition the many years
you watch the documentary and it's it's
it's really i mean the unfairness of it
it's frustrating and then it makes me
feel
hopeless like like what was the point of
it and then
it's reminding myself of
facts that i know things that i can
tether to the documentary did accomplish
something
i mean i think rain reported that
people were calling them at an increased
rate of like about 20
during the documentary which means that
survivors are out there connecting with
my story
and and healing from it it's bittersweet
thinking you know like this story
is something that connects
a lot of survivors who are
hurting and
okay what more can we do for them like
how
how can we make this this world a space
that women feel empowered or
feel at least less terrified
that is so well said thank you it really
is
what a perfect amazing answer to that
question
it's tough because like i wish that i
could say like here is
here is like you know a 10-step plan to
you know completely feeling healed and
fulfilled in your life
if you follow these steps you know
you're you're going to be just fine
i wish i had that what works for me
might not work for
somebody else so i think the best
the best advice that i offer is just
be true to yourself and
and and and and and the truth that you
have lived
as a last question uh you turned
to fantasy writing i did um
what do you get out of creating these
fantasy worlds for yourself and what do
you want other people
to get from them i think in a lot of
ways
seeing that sort of veil of fantasy is
a very appealing way for me to sort of
process stories that are
stories that i read how they relate to
myself
sort of um understanding them a little
bit better
maybe you know it's a metaphor or an
allegory of like a dragon
because like dragons are dragons are
cool dragons are awesome
and dragons are also really scary i was
gonna say they really represent
like the thing that you slay yes they
are
there to be overcome or they will eat
you alive
yes and it's a very it's the ultimate
metaphor for struggle is a dragon
in the metaphor of the book and the
closing
of that circle and that loop
what is your next chapter
well i'm actually really excited i
i've entered the editing phase
for the sequel to hush and
i'm looking at starting a whole new
writing project
and you know diving into something
completely different maybe
and also just you know continuing my
my little life in my little house with
my little family unit
and seeing seeing what else is on the
horizon
i feel like you know i feel like
good things are on the way i think that
is absolutely
full of hope full of strength thank you
so much um dylan farrow the four-part
hbo documentary
series allen versus pharaoh is available
on
hbo and hbo max and her book hush
is also available and apparently might
have a sequel
which is very exciting thank you
so much dylan for coming here this
conversation
everything i've been so looking forward
to it oh
seriously thank you thank you so much
everybody thank you so much